[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Karen is
with us in Jacksonville Florida hi Karen
how are you hi Dave hey what's up um I'm
doing well it's it's an honor to speak
to you you too how can we
help uh well my husband and I have
actually gone through Financial Peace
University and we're doing really well
uh we uh as of 2022 we were uh you know
had a a fully funded business Safeguard
account we had our emergency fund funded
we had no debt other than our house and
uh at that time my husband got a not so
good medical diagnosis uh so that set us
back that year and then ultimately he
decided to make a step into uh a
profession that he wanted to be in and
that essentially cut our income almost
in half for now um so he's doing he's
doing much better with that and and
moving forward progressing forward but
my question is um as a result of those
two things we we had to you know tap
into those Safeguard accounts and pretty
much depleted most of them and now we've
got from credit card debt we have some
stock that is not in any kind of
retirement account so my question to you
is do I sell that stock and pay that
little bit of credit card debt that that
we do have now or should I let that
stock sit and just continue to not
accumulate any more credit card debt but
you know just make payments on
that well what happens next
time what happens next time next time
there's a bump in the road and you land
on dadgum credit card again when are you
going to stop this
foolishness well um I mean we were able
to to do quite well for you know a while
and until you
didn't you know on until you started
Living on credit cards
again well we didn't really live on them
I mean yeah you did you bought crap you
couldn't afford to
buy well it was more monthly things that
we already had an obligation for um
because we weren't meeting our our
monthly budget so when you use the stock
to pay off the credit cards and the next
time you go on one of these Adventures
where you don't meet the monthly
obligations and you lean on credit cards
what are you going to do
then well I would hope he wouldn't be
back in this position I would hope you
wouldn't have been here this
time I'm not going to give you
permission to say what you did was okay
what you did was not okay it was a
really bad dumb plan and if you're going
to use every time something comes along
to get yourself back into credit card
debt I can't help
you cuz You' used up your stock then so
if I tell you to cash out the stock and
then you go do this again you're screwed
girl you follow
me yeah I guess this was kind of a
one-time no it's not a one time thing
though no it's not always life's going
to bring you
something it's always going to be
something coming up until you decide no
matter what let me tell you when the
time is we're going to use a credit card
at the Ramsay's never under any
circumstances we'll sell everything in
sight including the dog and three of the
grandkids we will never again go into a
credit card debt ever under any
circumstances period nothing will cause
that to happen we will be riding a
bicycle instead of driving a car but we
won't have debt ever see until you get
there kiddo you're going to go back
again you're G to go back again you're G
to go back again because there's always
something comes up because there's a
crack and as long as there's a crack in
the thing water's going to leak through
so yes you should cash out the stock and
you should pay off the credit cards but
you have got to the two of you have got
to sit down and go we flunked Financial
Peace University we flunked the
class so we have got to reset and draw a
line This s and say never under any
freaking
circumstances are we ever going to have
a credit card in our
house cut it up close the account
and then you won't have the opportunity
to be blessed with the 22% APR from
these credit card companies that's the
easiest way to do it cuz then you're
going to find another way when Deb's not
an option when Deb's off the table I got
a friend that lost his career he lost
his family he lost everything because of
a drinking problem he's now been dry for
30 years you know when he's going to
drink again never never you know when
the alcohol is going to be in his house
again never ever
you got to decide create your free every
dollar budget today the simplest way to
budget for your life